GABE WEISS: Hi, folks.
I'm Gabe Weiss, a developer
advocate for Google Cloud.
Today, I'd like to introduce
you to a new product--
Database Migration
Service, or DMS.
I'm also going to walk through
a quick, simple migration
to Cloud SQL using it.
Database migration service
makes it fast and easy
to move your MySQL or PostgreSQL
database to our managed Cloud
SQL service.
DMS provides a simple,
integrated experience
to guide you through every
step of the migration.
It's serverless,
so you don't need
to worry about managing
or monitoring instances.
And continuous data
replication means
you can cut over with
minimal downtime.
Whether your database
is on premise,
self-hosted in Google Cloud,
or running on another Cloud,
DMS helps you quickly unlock the
benefits of managed Cloud SQL.
Now, let's walk through
the DMS experience
for a new migration job.
You can access DMS from the
Google Cloud console navigation
under Databases.
Just click Database Migration.
To get started, you'll
create a migration job.
This represents the
end-to-end process
of moving your source database
to a Cloud SQL destination.
First, let's define what kind
of migration the job will run.
I want to move a
MySQL database I
am running on GCE to Cloud SQL.
I can choose between one-time
or a continuous replication.
I'll select continuous
for minimal downtime.
Once I've defined
my job, DMS shows
me the source and
connectivity configuration
required to be able to connect
to and migrate the source
database.
DMS makes it easy
to know what I need
to do to prepare by showing
me the prerequisites directly
in the UI.
It also supports the setup
of multiple networking
connectivity options, including
secure private connectivity
with built-in scripts
for easy execution.
If I need to make changes to
the configuration of my source
database, I can click
Save and Exit to pick up
where I left off later.
I'm ready to define my source.
I can do this by creating a
connection profile, a resource
that represents the
information needed
to connect to a database.
These profiles aren't locked
to an individual migration.
This means I can reuse it
if I want to first test out
a migration or if someone
else in my organization
is in charge of connecting
to the database.
I have already created
a connection profile
for a MySQL database running
on GCE, so I'll select it.
Now I'm ready to create the
Cloud SQL instance that I'll
migrate my database to.
This will feel familiar to
anyone that's created a Cloud
SQL instance before.
You'll see many of
the same options,
like connectivity and
machine configuration.
Since DMS relies on the
replication technology
of the Database Engine, I don't
have to create resources, aside
from the Cloud SQL
instance I've just defined.
I'm ready to define how my
new instance will securely
connect to my source
database for continuous data
replication.
I have a few options.
I can choose to allowlist the
IP address of the Cloud SQL
destination on the
database sources machine.
I can set up
private connectivity
through a reverse SSH tunnel
on a VM in my project.
Or I can set up VPC peering.
Since my source is already
running on Google Cloud,
I'll choose VPC peering.
And that was easy.
I've configured my source,
created a Cloud SQL
destination, and established
connectivity between them.
All that's left is to validate
the migration job setup
and start my migration.
My migration job validation
passed successfully.
I can trust that my
migration will run smoothly.
I'll create and start the
job to run it immediately.
Once my migration
job has started,
I can monitor its
progress and see
if it encounters any issues.
DMS will first transfer
the initial snapshot
of existing data, then
continuously replicate changes
as they happen.
And since DMS is
serverless, I never
have to worry about the
migration resources themselves.
That's it.
I've quickly and easily
shown you one of the ways
to migrate a MySQL database out
of GCE and into Cloud SQL using
DMS.
When the initial snapshot's
migrated and continuous
replication is keeping up,
I can promote Cloud SQL
to be my primary instance
and point my applications
to work directly against it.
Google Cloud's new
database migration service
is the fast, easy,
and reliable way
to migrate with minimal downtime
to a managed Cloud SQL database
for both MySQL and PostgreSQL.
It's serverless, high
performance, and free to use.
And now it's your
turn to give it a try.
You can get started from
the Google Cloud console,
or learn more by following
the links in the description.
Thanks for watching.